[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الهم الانباء من العربيه
نشرت القياده المركزيه الامريكيه صورا
لاقتراب مقاتله روسيه من مقاتلات ومصيرات
الامريكيه في الاجواء السوريه ووصف بيان
للقياده المركزيه الخطوه الروسيه بالسلوك
غير المهني في المقابل قالت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان مسيرات تابعه للتحالف الدولي
بقياده الولايات المتحده انتهى كت خمس
مرات المجال الجوي لمنطقه تدريبات سوريه
روسيه مشتركه واكدت موسكو انها غير مسؤوله
عن سلامه رحلات الجويه غير المنسقه
للمسيرات معربه عن قلقها ازاء تلك
الانتهاكات على حد تعبيرها
قالت البحريه الامريكيه النيران حاولت
الاستيلاء على ناقلتي نفط قرب مضيق هرمز
واطلقتا النار على احداهما واوضح المتحدث
باسم الاسطول الخامس للبحريه الامريكيه
ان السفن البحريه الايرانيه تراجعت بعد ان
استجابت البحريه الامريكيه لاشارات
الاستغاثه ومنعت الاستيلاء على السفينتين
وانا ناقلتي النفط واصلت رحلاتهما
الى ان اطلاق البحريه الايرانيه النار على
احدى السفينتين لم يتسبب في وقوع اي
اصابات او اضرار في المقابل نفى مصدر
عسكري ايراني لوكاله الانباء الايرانيه
محاوله استهلاء البحريه الايرانيه على
ناقلتي النفط قربى نضيق
ابدا الاتحاد التوروسيه للشغل بصفاق
قسنزعاجه من التطور الاخير للاوضاع في
المدينه نتيجه تزايد حالات العنف والخروج
عن القانون لما وصفها بالاعداد الغفيره
للمهاجرين الافارقه غير النظاميين وهرب
الاتحاد في بيان عن تضامنه مع كل اهالي
صفاقس امام ما وصفه بالوضع الخطير الذي
يعيشونه الان محملا السلطات التونسيه
مسؤوليه ما الت اليه الاوضاع ومطالبا
الحكومه بضروره التحرك الاتحاد التونسي
لشغل اعتبر ان تقصير الحكومه في تعاملها
مع ازمه المهاجرين غير النظاميين زاد في
تعميقها
بدوره دعا رئيس مجلس النواب التونسي
ابراهيم ابو درباله الى انقاذ مدينه صفاقس
وذلك بعدما شهدته من اشتباكات على مدى
ثلاث ليال متتاليه بين سكان المحليين
ومهاجرين غير شرعيين
ونحن المجلس نقول باسمكم جميعا ان نتعاطف
مع اهلنا في صفاقس
ونطلب من
سياده
رئيس الجمهوريه
رئيس الوظيفه التنفيذيه
وهو
غير مقصر في ذلك
اتخاذ كل ما يلزم
لحمايه امن البلاد
ولانقاذ مدينه صفاقس
الى المثوى الاخير يشيع قتيل صفاقس على يد
مهاجرين غير نظاميين والى المجهول ينقل
مئات المهاجرين عقابا كما يراه حقوقيون
تلجا سلطات الى خيار الترحيل نحو جنوب
البلاد بالقرب من الحدود الليبيه
منظمات حقوقيه تخشى على المهاجرين لا سيما
الاطفال والنساء من مصير مجهول في ظل حديث
عن نقلهم الى منطقه عسكريه عازله في
الجنوب خطوه ترى فيها منظمات حقوقيه انها
قد تتسبب في ازمه دبلوماسيه مع ليبيا لكن
ازمه داخليه تتنام مع تنام احتقان سكان
صفاقس وغضبهم من تزايد اعدادهم في المدينه
تعد سواحل صفاقس المطله على البحر الابيض
المتوسط نقطه انطلاق للمهاجرين الافارقه
نحو اوروبا وهي نقطه يرفضها راس الدوله
ولا يريد لبلاده ان تكون ممرا او وطنا
بديلا او حارسه الا لحدودها الرئيس قيس
سعيد اتهم شبكات اجراميه لم يسميها
بالوقوف وراء عمليات الهجره غير النظاميه
[موسيقى]
وعلى واقع التوتر وصدامات بين المهاجرين
وتونسيين في صفاقس دخلت قناه العربيه الى
حي الحفاره في المدينه الساحليه الحي الذي
بات يعرف منذ ان تدفق اليه الاف المهاجرين
بحي الافارقه او ربما حي انتظار العبور
الى الضفه الاوروبيه عبر قوارب الموت
[موسيقى]
هذا هو حي الافارقه في القاره السمراء بلى
ولكنه ليس من دولا في جنوب الصحراء وانما
في اقصى شمالها حيث تونس وشرقها الذي يغص
بالاف عابر السبيل اتوا الى صفاقس
لينتظروا رحله الحياه وربما الموت مهاجرون
او مهجرون لا فرق كلاهما يعاني حملا مرهقا
ووعودا من شبكات التهريب التي تستخسر فيهم
راكب مضمونه تجربيهم يدوم اللسان
الموت ب 30 مليون 30 الف دينار وهي من
الحديد اول ما تهبط في البحر اول موجه
تلقاها يمشيو شويه وبعد تغرق بهم
وفي دائره النسيان تقريبا هنا بين الازقه
تواروا عن انظار عدسات كاميرا العربيه
خشيه من تعرضهم لمواقف تخدش انسانيتهم
بدعوى انهم غير مرغوب بهم وربما خوفا من
امساكهم وزجهم في السجون لانهم دخلوا بلا
اوراق قانونيه
تتراكم عليهم الاعباء اثقلت كواهلهم كحال
بلادهم وكذا اصابتهم بالاعياءات اليوم
نحكي على امراض كما السل جوج حالات وفاه
الاسبوع اللي فات
تسعه وستين اصابه نحكي على امراض السيده
يجلسون على عتبات الاماكن العامه لا مكان
يستلقون فيه ويضمد تعبهم يجد الشباب ساحه
فيلعبون بها ريثما تدق ساعه الابحار
المنتظره حالات فقر وحالات معناتها حاله
هجوم على الديار حاله سرقه اليوم تخرج ما
قبلوهمش السودانيين الجنسيات الاخرين
والصراع بيناتهم بل بالصواطر
يتجولون حتى التعب فياخذون استراحه محارب
ينشرون ثيابهم بين الاسوار الحديديه
يتسامرون ليخففوا عن وجدانهم
يعيشون بين امل وحال يرثى له في تونس
المحطه العابره مترقبين ساعه الارتحال الى
الضفه الاخرى من المتوسط
لكنهم قيد انتظار تعهد المهربين المعلق
اسراء الصغير العربيه
هجمات تلفزيون الروسيه رسمي بشكل لذي
عقائد مجموعه فاجناريا غينيا
وبطت القناه صورا وصفت بانها وصلت بانها
حصريه
لمداهمات امنيه لمكتب بروجن في
احد عقارات هناك كما اجرت القناه الروسيه
الحكوميه مداخلات مع مسؤولين اتهموا قائد
بالخيانه مشيره الى انه يجري البحث عن
شركائه في التمرد وذلك لمحاكمتهم
ومعاقبتهم
ان التحقيق في التمرد ما زال مستمرا ولم
يغلق بعد
وبموجب الاتفاق الذي انهت فان بروجن كان
من المفترض ان ينتقل الى بيلاروسيا
المجاوره مقابل اسقاط التهم الجنائيه
الموجهه اليك
ميدانيا نشرت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
مقطعا مصورا لتقدم قواتها في معارك بريه
قربه بخموت وافديفكا
وقالت الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها خاضت
اربعين اشتباكا في محاور القتال بدونيت
خلال 24 ساعه واضافه سلاح الجو الاوكراني
نفذ 17 غاره على تمركزات وانظمه صواريخ
روسيه
السلطات الاوكرانيه اعلنت انهاء المرحله
الاولى من الهجوم المضاد ضد جيش الروسي
وبدات المرحله الثانيه لكن هذا البدء
استانف بقصف المدن حيث قصفت القوات
الاوكرانيه قلب مدينه دانيت باعداد من
الصواريخ والقذائف التي اصابت احياء مدنيه
قتيلين وعده اصابات في حي بتروفيكا في
مقاطعه او مدينه دنيسك وهنا في مدينه حيث
نقف الان هذه هي المستشفى الثانيه مدينه
تلقت اربعه صواريخ من طراز هايمرز صاروخان
تصدت لهم الدفاعات الجويه واثنين اخرين
سقطا في هذه المنطقه واحدهما سقط في هذه
المشفى
كنا نجلس في البيت انا واختي وعندما توجهت
للخروج وفتحت باب المنزل وسمعت ذلك
الانفجار الكبير بعد عده ضربات اثناء
القصف فعلا اصابني الذعر تقول القوات
الروسيه بانها تتصدى للعمليات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه المضاده وان سلاح الجو الروسي
او الدفاعات الجويه تتصدى للقصف الاوكراني
المستمر على المدن لقناتي العربيه والحدث
رائد الاغبر
وعلى وقع تبادل الهجمات بين اوكرانيا
وروسيا تتصاعد التصريحات حول الاسلحه
النوويه نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الروسي قال ان الحرب في اوكرانيا يمكن
انهائها بسرعه اما بسلام او باستخدام
الاسلحه النوويه تتزامن هذه التصريحات مع
التهابات متبادله بين موسكو وكيف حول
التخطيط لضرب محطه النوويه
اما السلام او النووي خياران لا ثالث لهما
يضعهما نائب رئيس المجلس الامن القومي
الروسي على طاوله الحرب والغرب تلك هي
سيناريوهات نهايه الحرب بلسان ديمتري جرت
بالتاكيد من حنجره رئيسه فلاديمير بوتين
حديث الاسلحه النوويه يتصاعد ويتردد صداه
في موسكو وكيف مرورا بزاف بوريجيا وابعد
من ذلك
القاطعه سبقها تكذيب الكرمل لتقارير غربيه
تحدثت عن تحذير وجهه الرئيس الصيني لبوتين
من استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
لغه تريد موسكو على ما يبدو ان تسمع جيدا
من حليفتها بكين وفي كييف وعواصم غربيه
تمدها بسلاح يقول ان نهايه الحرب مرهونه
بوقف امداده كل ذلك يتزامن مع خطر يتصاعد
عنوانه محطه زابوريجيا النوويه هناك تحوم
شكوك حول عمليه ما تتربص بالمحطه يخرج
الرئيس الاوكراني متكئا على معلومات
استخباراتيه وصفها بالاكيده عن تفخيخ
روسيا اسطح مفاعلين نوويين بعبوات ناسفه
معلومات مخابراتنا تفيد بان الجيش الروسيه
وضع مواد شبيهه بالمتفجرات على سطح عدد من
وحدات الطاقه في محطه الطاقه النوويه في
زابوري
يحذر ايضا من عمل تخربي اوكراني في المحطه
وصف تداعياته بالكارثيه
فيزابوريجيا تمت قناع اوكرانيه بان موسكو
تريد تمرير سيناريوهات عبر محطه الطاقه
النوويه في المقابل ترى موسكو ان خطرا
حقيقيا يدبر في كييف الثابت في المعادله
ان محطه زابوريجيا في مرمى النيران استهدف
محيطها سابقا مرات لكن ايا منها لم يصب
قلب المفاعلات وان حدث ستنقلب المعادلات
الطاقه النوويه ليست مزحه خذنا ذلك من قبل
انها شيء مخيف من حيث المبدا نامل ان لا
يحدث شيء خطير كان نتابع عن كتب كما يفعل
انا شخصيا لا اعتقد انهم سيفجرونها او
يفجرون شيئا فيها سيكون ذلك هجوما ارهابيا
يهدف الى تخويف الناس
السلطات عن اخلاء جماعي فسنغادر بالطبع
ونحمل بعض المتعلقات الشخصيه معنا على
الرغم من اننا لا نريد ذلك بالطبع
يجب ان لا يخاف الذين استعدوا على المرء
ان يقرا ويستمع الى العلماء ويثق في مصادر
الاخبار الاوكرانيه التي لا تنشر الذعره
والاكاذيب
ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد الفاصل
الاتحاد الاوروبي يدعو لمحاسبه مرتكبي
الفضائع بسودان ومستشفيات وصدافور متوقفه
تماما
اهلا بكم من جديد دعا مسؤول سياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزي
لمحاسبه المسؤولين عما وصفها بالفضائع في
السودان ووقف حاله الافلات من العقاب وكدا
بوريل في بيان للاتحاد ان الاتحاد مستعد
لاستخدام كافه الوسائل المتاحه لديه
للمساهمه في انهاء الصراع في السودان
[موسيقى]
اكد رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقاليه عبد
الفتاح البرهان في اتصال مع الرئيس
الصومالي ان الحكومه السودانيه لم تدخر
جهدا لوقف الحرب عبر طرق السلميه كما جدد
البرهان رفض حكومه السودان رئاسه كينيا
للجنه الرباعيه بشان معالجه الازمه في
السودان والتي نتجت عن قمه دول الايجاد
الاخيره التي استضافتها جيبوتي
وعلى الارض المتحدث الاعلامي باسم محافظه
ولايه الجزيره في السودان الفاتح حاجبه
بكر ان عدد الوافدين الى الولايه يتراوح
ما بين ثلاثه الى اربعه ملايين شخص نجحوا
من ولايه الخرطوم بعد اندلاع الحرب اوضح
حاج بن بكر في بيان الله ان ولايه الجزيره
واحده من اكثر الولايات السودانيه التي
تشهد استقرارا امنيا الامر الذي دفع
ملايين السودانيين الى اللجوء اليها
قال وزير الصحه والرعايه الاجتماعيه
بحكومه اقليم دارفور بابا بكر حمدين ان
جميع مستشفيات ولايه وسط دارفور متوقفه
تماما عن العمل واضاف حمدان بان جميع
البراكز الصحيه في مدينه زالنجي عاصمه
ولايه
توقفت عن العمل بسبب غياب الامن باستثناء
مركز واحد شرقي المدينه يعمل بشكل محدود
ايضا ناشد بيان للجنه اطباء السودان
الكوادر الطبيه لتقديم المساعده للمصابين
والحالات الحرجه في ظل القتال الدائر
بمدينه ام درمان ما بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع وطلب بيان اللجنه الكوادر الطبيه
بالتوجه الى المستشفيات للمساعده في اسعاف
المصابين مشيرا الى الحاجه الماسه لجراحين
واطباء طوارئ وباطنيه
قال مكتب رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بن
يمينه ياهو ان ميليشيا حزب الله العراقي
اختطفت منذ اشهر اسرائيليه تحمل الجنسيه
الروسيه واوضح مكتب نتنياهونا الاسرائيليه
الروسيه المحتجزه في العراق على قيد
الحياه وحمل بغداد مسؤوليه سلامتها ابا
وتحدد ان اسم المراه هو اليزابيث
وتعمل في الحقل الاكاديمي وبحسب مصدر في
الاستخبارات العراقيه فانها اختطفت في
بغداد في نهايه مارس الماضي واضاف مصدر
اسرائيلي ان المختطف ليست عميله موساد
وزاره سوريا من قبل مشيره او مشيرا الى ان
التقارير تقدر ان الخاطفين كانوا يعرفون
بانها اسرائيلي
وعلى صعيد اخر قال رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو الى العمليه
الواسعه في جنين هي تعبير عن تغيير في
سياسه وتغيير في المعادله
بولان خفت بالجنين العمليه الواسعه في
جنين هي تعبير عن تغيير في السياسه وتغيير
في المعادله ونحن لا نعتمد على رد الفعل
بل المبادره وقواتنا ستستمر في العمل في
اي لحظه عندما تكون هناك حاجه اليها
في مقابله مع العربيه قال سفيره التركيه
لدى مصر صالح موت لوشن ان الدولتين
تمكنتان من بناء الثقه بينهما وانهما
تعملان حاليا على تعزيز التعاون بما يحقق
مصالح مصر وتركيا
اعتقد ان مرتكز الحوار السياسي والعلاقات
السياسيه قائم على الثقه بين اي دولتين
ومع ذلك فقد كنا في خضم هذه العمليه في
السنوات الثلاث او الاربع الماضيه وتمكنا
من بناء الثقه بين البلدين واكدت الدولتان
على الالتزام بتعزيز العلاقات والتعاون
لصالح الشعبين لذلك سنتفق على عمليات او
اليه التعاون السياسي كما قلت من الزيارات
رفيعه المستوى والزيارات على مستوى القاده
او وزراء الخارجيه او الاجتماعات الرسميه
التي بدات بالفعل وكذلك المشاورات
السياسيه واشكال التعاون الاخرى
السفينه التركيه لدى مصر قال ان مصر
وتركيا متفقتان على الحوار في الملف
الليبي لضمان امن ليبيا ووحدتها
واستقرارها وصولا لعقد الانتخابات
اعتقد انه بمجرد اقامه العلاقات الكامله
بين البلدين الشقيقين فانهما سيعملان على
تعزيز الحوار والاستشارات حول ليبيا لضمان
استقرارها وامنها وتحدثنا عن ليبيا مع
الجانب المصري واعتقد ان البلدين يتفهمان
بعضهما بشكل افضل ونعمل على احراز تقدم في
بناء الثقه بين بعضنا على اساس الحفاظ على
وحده وسلامه الاراضي الليبيه وحمايتها
اطلقت شركه ماتات تطبيقات وهو منصه جديده
نصيه منافسه لتويتر مما يشكل اكبر تهديد
حتى للمنصه التي يملكها الى الماسك وكتب
مارك زوكربيرج رئيسه التنفيذي لشركه متى
ومؤسس فيسبوك في اول منشور له على المنصه
الوليد لننطلق مرحبا بكم
كشفت صحفنا امريكيه عن الجدول اليومي
للملياردير الى الماسك كيف يمضي يومه وكيف
باستطاعته ان يدير اربع شركات ومليارات
الاستثمارات ما بين الارض والسماء في وقت
واحد
غريب الاطوار احيانا لكنه معروف بكفاءته
التي لا تعرف حدودا يكفي انه يدير اربع
شركات في ان واحد انه الملياردير الامريكي
الشهير ايلون ماسك الذي يعمل لساعات
مجنونه على حد تعبيره فكيف يمضي هذا
الخمسيني يومه ويوازن بين مناصبه
التنفيذيه والحياه يقول ماسك ان نهاره
يبدا من السابعه صباحا يصحو عيناهم
متلهفتان لتفتيش الهاتف ومعاينه البريد
الالكتروني هذا اذا غادر المكتب لان التعب
يغلبه فيغفو داخل غرفه الاجتماعات صحيح
انه يعشق طبق العجه ويتخطى الافطار مرتشفا
القهوه سريعا لكنه لا يفوت الاستحمام
الفقره المنعشه حتى لافكاره تحتد الشمس
وتبدا افه الاجتماعات المهلكه قد يغادرها
اذا شعر بان وقته بدا يضيع هنا قد يتناول
الغداء او ينغمس في العمل مجددا واحيانا
قد لا يسعفه الوقت فيغرد من المرحاض ومن
العادي جدا ان تكون تغريداته قرارات
فجائيه تماما كما يفعل في تويتر اوشك ان
ينتهي اليوم يعود اخيرا عند العاشره مساء
الى المنزل بعد ان نام اطفاله يتذكر ان
الجوع كافر فياكل بشراهه حتى الشبع ثم
يقرا الكتب ويشاهد الرسوم المتحركه الى ان
يستسلم للنعاس عند الواحده فجرا هي ست
ساعات نوم تكفيها ليتكرر جدوله الزمني ولا
ريب ان شابته بعض التغييرات لانه قد يضطر
للسفر لكنه يحاول ما امكن ان يخصص الاثنين
والجمعه في لوس انجلوس او المكسيك وبقيه
الاسبوع في سان فرانسيسكو اسراء الصغير
العربيه
شهدت مدينه لاهور ثاني اكبر المدن اقتضاضا
بسكان في باكستان هطولا موسميه عرقله
سياره الحياه في البلاد وبلغ حجم الامطار
نحو
272 مليمتر خلال الساعات الاخيره الامر
الذي جعلك كميه كبيره من المياه تملا
الشوارع وتدخل البيوت بما ان هذه
الفيضانات في باكستان قد الحقت عام 20 22
ضررا باكثر من 33 مليون شخص لاكثر من 90
منطقه في البلاد مما يعزز المخاوف بلغت
حصيره الضحايا اكثر من 700 شخص بما قدرت
الاختصارات الخسائر الاقتصاديه حينها ب 30
مليار دولار الى العالم
واشنطن تنتهي مطيرات روسيه بالاقتراب
بمقاتلاتها في سوريا وموسكوت تتحدث عن
انتهاك الامريكي لمنطقه التدريبات
الاتحاد التونسي للشغل يعرب عن تضامنه مع
صفاقس امام المهاجرين
وشركه متى تطلق
لمنافسه تويتر
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات